ignore all that stuff about last time
where we said we hated you I'll do it
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
sharp white I'm having a romantic
situation with a dinosaur so yeah he
could be upstairs the door the door yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
five across the head back to the door on
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
gently just kind of slap him around a
little bit with the blunt end to the axe
yeah there we go there we go that's what
I wanted good god everything is gonna be
fine
what have I got a hold up I thought I
had the lung maybe I had something else
or what oh god well Davin add that boat
you havin
all right know that you know that yo
fire the cannon fire fire
shirt okay I'm not going down there ever
oh god damn it jingle bells go to hell I
hope you die today but I'm coming to
kill you and nothing you can say will
stop me five more I'll make a promise
this has been markiplier highlights
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video and you'd like to see more than
please leave a like to let me know links
to all the videos are available in the
description below so check them out and
if you have a video that you want to see
in a highlights reel later let me know
in the comments below thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye